a u.n report out this morning says the
risks of climate change are growing and
countries around the world need to do
more to adapt to the dangerous impacts
that are coming senior national and
environmental correspondent ben tracy
has seen the report and ben there's some
serious stuff in there good morning
good morning nate serious stuff indeed
this report by the world's leading
climate scientists is released just once
every eight years and it's pretty grim
it says the impacts of climate change
are accelerating that we're not adapting
to them quickly enough and we're running
out of time the report says the planet
is now facing increased risks of intense
and extreme heat waves droughts
wildfires and floods that are already
impacting billions of people climate
change is also taking a huge toll on the
natural world with massive losses of
forests coral reefs the world's ice
sheets and some animal species now
scientists warn we need to take
unprecedented steps to more quickly
adapt to climate change because our
current infrastructure including our
power grids is not resilient enough now
there are also big concerns about
coastal areas due to rising sea levels
john kerry the biden administration
special envoy for climate he says that
further climate change denial or delay
is a recipe for disaster there is some
good news here if we do reduce planet
warming emissions we can still avoid
some of the worst impacts of climate
change nate
we have to take care of the planet so we
can take care of us ben thank you